after having written your own script
having been a college professor you
decided to go back to school for
screenwriting is it what made you want
to take that leap what made you think
that you didn't know enough about the
topic well so when I decided to go back
to Cal State Northridge for a second
master's degree I was met with a lot of
skepticism from my friends and my family
and basically everyone I know for a long
time I wanted to be a professional
screenwriter that was the entry that I
had into the business I started writing
first and that led me to getting
involved in production excuse me I
wanted to try to make it as a
professional screenwriter before making
it as a filmmaker but when I went to
Florida State I quickly found out that I
was good at producing and as people know
in the business if you're good at
something you immediately start getting
work at it and you get pigeonholed in
that very quickly so that sort of turned
me into a producer and it was hard to
break out of that I worked for about 10
years as a location manager a production
manager producer and it was great and
that wonderful people worked on
wonderful films but that really wasn't
what I wanted to do so that was part of
what led me to try to make Rising Star
the first feature that I made because I
wrote the script and I wanted to have it
produced so the easiest way to do that
it's just to make it on your own I say
easy the really the overriding thing was
I know I'm not getting any younger at
the time I was 39 and I thought if I'm
gonna do this and if I'm really gonna
dedicate myself to trying to be a writer
it needs to happen now so after two
years of working at Chapman University I
decided okay I'm gonna go back to school
full time I'm gonna get through this I'm
gonna spend two years and concentrate on
writing and really bettering myself as a
writer it was really out of a desire to
really focus on that for a little while
and then just see what happens
you know if if nothing happened after
that time I could go back to working and
know that at least I tried so I got into
Cal State Northridge and they were kind
enough to offer me a job on the staff of
their film school as well so that was
great I worked as a student resource
supervisor there for two years I ran the
script library which was totally on
brand and it was two wonderful years and
I wrote a TV spec for the show black
mirror and that place in the Austin Film
Fest the screenwriting competition I
wrote three features one of which I'm
directing right now it was it really was
the right move it was an unusual move
but it did a couple things like it gave
me time to focus on writing which is
something that I really wanted to do it
gave me a chance to kind of reset my
life a little bit because I was really
getting into the producing track again
when I moved out here because again when
you're good at something and people keep
you in that track you know whether it's
in the business or academia it's that's
very true you know and and it really
gave me time to kind of tell the stories
that I wanted to tell but that I didn't
have time to the thesis script that I
wrote which I'm hoping to direct one day
is a story about the death of my father
and I had been toying with it for
probably six seven years but I never had
the time and the energy to sit down and
actually write it and now I do and how I
can hold it so it needs work
but it exists and that's a benefit of
going to school that you know that I
think is really important to me so yeah
that's why what was it like being a
student on the first day it was
interesting the grad program that I was
in we had about I think 12 students in
our class at the beginning of the
program and I actually wasn't the oldest
one there were four students that were
older than me
three of them ended up dropping out
really over the course of the program
and
it was because they had family
responsibilities they had job
responsibilities and that sort of
overtook their desire to get through the
program so once we graduated I think I
was the second oldest in the class so
that really wasn't too much of a
transition like it didn't feel to me
like I was in an undergraduate classroom
that would have been a pretty severe
thing if I was the oldest person in the
class by 20 years but where there was a
big transition was where I was working
on staff my job was I was the manager of
the script library at the film school
and I had a group of interns that worked
for me every semester so I would have
over the course of the semester you know
anywhere from 8 to 15 undergrads that
I'd be interfacing with every single day
and that was really a big challenge
because I realized very quickly that I
was out of touch with what young people
were talking about and what they cared
about and issues that they talked a lot
about CSUN is definitely a very activist
campus yes so that was something I was
looking forward to being a part of but I
didn't realize just how fervent it was
and being involved with the students
every day and talking with them about
the news and things like that it really
brought home to me you know what issues
kids care about and I think that'll help
me you know as I go on you know as a
teacher and you know also just being
able to kind of understand what kind of
stories people are looking for in the
film marketplace as well so that was a
big transition but I think it was a
really good one yeah a Generation X
wasn't really much of a sort of an
activist generation I know our parents
were right but but yeah and and maybe
were more so now as Alderaan before but
yeah that's something that I was very
surprised at to to see how much younger
people hey whatever whether they're 35
or whatever that you know that care
about their very issue based cos based
and it was very surprised at that yeah
and the neat thing too about Cal State
Northridge is how how diverse the
student population is you know obviously
I'm a
it's straight white guy I'm not exactly
what they're looking for but being able
to work with students from all over the
world it really was great like they're
the Latino population at CSUN is I it's
almost a majority oh wow yeah they're
they're a Latino serving institution as
well as a Pacific Islander serving
institution so they focus on working to
help those students from those
backgrounds so every semester I had
students from Mexico from Spain Portugal
Puerto Rico like from all over the
Spanish world and we would work together
and you know we talk about like what
movies did we enjoy and why did you like
that and you know when Black Panther
came out that was a great example every
student of color that I worked with saw
at that first weekend and it was a
transformative experience for them
because they had never seen that on
screen before and that didn't hit home
for me until I heard them talking about
it being Frank
you know I saw it the first weekend and
I really enjoyed it but I never thought
of it as a cultural touchstone until I
heard other students of color talking
about how unbelievable it was that they
finally saw themselves on screen as a
superhero so that was a great
opportunity you know being in that
environment you know some other schools
are you know a little more whitewashed I
guess I'm probably the best term um that
that's a great thing to have been part
of to have witnessed so that really I
mean that helped me you know and my and
my growth you know as a as a human being
seeing that were you hearing them on
campus not not just to you with the
interns but were you hearing them
conversations oh yeah absolutely
when black panther came out you know
there was there was that with the
african-american community when Captain
Marvel came out all the female students
that I worked with we're talking about
that you know and you think of these
superhero films as not really cultural
touchstones right but these students are
really taking it seriously because
that's the content that they consume the
most and when they see these things
happening it's a big deal it really is a
big deal so you know you so a lot of
people sort of brushed films like that
off but when you look at how that
audience is consuming it it's it's a
powerful thing
you